all right uh so what happens now with no
border relief coming anytime soon let's
go to Brad Kell to Kenny County Texas
sheriff and Sheriff un last we talked I
mean you you you were hopeful but you
weren't really naive about it that that
it's a leap for politicians to get on
the same page and do something and they
didn't uh what happens
now good morning Neil um what happens
now it it falls back on the on the local
law enforcement uh border patrol in our
area is nonexistent they are all down
the processing center taking care of
what needs to be processed there so that
leaves our area wide open uh the union
president did state that it's not going
to be a happy holidays for the board
Patrol AG but it's not going to be happy
holidays for my deputies either because
we're all going to be working to fill in
that void uh Governor Abbott has taken
steps to make it uh a state misdemeanor
for them to be here illegally and that
goes into effect March 4th but from now
until March 4th we're just kind of uh
hanging out in the breeze if you know
what I mean yeah I would imagine as we
look live at Eagle Pass where you know
crowds are building again but I did want
to ask you how that order on the part of
Governor Abbott is going to go through
as you know a lot of people shareff are
leading an effort uh to to slap it down
that the governor went a step too far
that that's not something you and your
men and women can or should be doing um
it obviously adds to your already
substantial uh you know assignments and
burdens how do you feel about that and
how you implement
that well we're going to have sit down
with our attorney make sure that we've
got all our ducks in row but it's more
of designed to be more of a deterrent
than it is anything else in my books yes
we once it goes into effect we will be
making those arrest and uh proceed with
prosecution but I think it's supposed to
be more of a deterrent than anything
else and if it works
great so when it is a deterrent and of
course there are people you deter in the
process and you have to arrest in the
process how does that
go well the way it'll work is if we C if
we apprehend them in say a smuggling
Endeavor we'll go through the process
we'll put them in jail with uh present
them to the court and they'll have the
option there to either a return to their
home country or B spend up to 180 days
in
jail Sheriff what is behind this
incredible Spike of the numbers they've
always been high and you've always you
know shared with us what's going on but
it seems like in just the last couple of
weeks Sheriff it it went nuts what was
the catalyst is there some Mission uh
being sent out cartels on a new drive to
get people through the border to the
Border what is
it well the part of it is the the
cartels are controlling what's going
what the narrative is in on the Mexican
side and further south so once you've
got that bar that uh lack of
communication or the the way they change
things around here comes that push now
granted Venezuela and a few other
countries in Central America are having
some severe uh economic issues some
severe political issues the cartels are
exploiting that and once they know that
they can push them through here in large
numbers in certain areas it opens up
their ability to push through the the
dope and the undesirables those that
have criminal records those that are the
the rapist etc etc to come into the
country is Mexico doing anything to
eleviate this
process honestly they say they are but I
at this point I don't believe it had a
conversation with the gentleman the
other day that was here illegally uh he
was from E uh Ecuador I believe and he
had a permit that allowed him he entered
into Mexico illegally they gave him a
transit Visa as long as he was going to
the United States they weren't going to
harass him they weren't going to arrest
him they weren't going to try to to put
send him home so Mexico I think is part
of the problem because they're not
enforcing their immigration laws as long
as the people are saying that they're
coming to the United States they're just
letting them go
just incredible I don't know how you do
it sh but you try to do it you and and
your men and women are to be thanked for
that Brad Co the uh Ken County Texas
sheriff sheriff have a Merry Christmas
or try to my friend try to thank you
again you too have a Merry Christmas and
a great New Year hi everyone I'm Brian
kilme I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now